c'est par un vote qui a débuté cette
assemblée générale des Nations unies
objectif savoir de quelle manière les
pays membres se prononceront sur la
résolution en cours de débat la Russie
réclamait un vote à bulletin secret mais
pas moins de 107 pays ici sont opposés
il s'agit donc d'un premier revers pour
Moscou accusé par l'Ukraine de crime de
guerre
le fait de prendre délibérément pour
cible des civils est un crime de guerre
en lançant des attaques de missiles sur
des civils dormants chez eux ou se
rendant au travail sur des enfants
allant à l'école la Russie encore une
fois prouver qu'elle était un état
terroriste que l'on doit dissuader de la
plus forte des manières
impossible de ne pas commenter les
dernières frappes russes
particulièrement meurtrières mais à
l'origine cette assemblée générale était
organisée suite à l'annexion par Moscou
de quatre régions ukrainiennes afin de
combattre d'une éventuelle condamnation
la Russie ne s'en défend pas elle
contre-attaque comparant à son tour
l'Ukraine à une organisation terroriste
la preuve de ce que le régime de Kiev
peut faire
et le sabotage du pont de Crimée nous
avons prévenu que cela ne se fera pas en
toute impunité
lorsque vous réalisez ces actes de
sabotage lorsque vous tuez ceux qui vous
sont défavorables le régime de Kiev est
au même niveau que les organisations
terroristes les plus scandaleuses pour
être voté la résolution doit recueillir
les deux tiers des voies des 183 membres
de l'ONU un résultat incertain en raison
de la lassitude de bon nombre d'états de
voir les occidentaux les yeux rivés sur
l'Ukraine des Occidentaux qui eux
souhaitent isoler un peu plus la Russie
sur la scène internationale